our series of more perfect union shows
that what unites us as americans is far
greater than what divides us and this
morning we highlight a trailblazer who's
opening up
new worlds of possibility jimmy yukis
introduces us to teresa price who
created
the black college expo to help close the
education gap
in underserved communities and change
lives
routines get students excited about
school but each step at the black
college expo
is toward a brighter future with
students getting scholarships on the
spot
lauren crawford recalls how the expo
changed his life
i remember growing up and thinking that
if i wanted to make a million dollars i
had to be an athlete or a musician or
black college expert showed me that no
you can be an engineer
from vale victorian to phd crawford is
now a senior researcher at microsoft
and a professor at brown because the
expo
opened doors i am
amazing amazing
teresa price is the pioneering
powerhouse who first launched the expo
two decades ago she's helped more than a
half million people get into college
i just love seeing their eyes brighten
up when they know they can do it that's
my
warm and fuzzy my advice my everything
this is price's second act after a
successful career in radio
and marketing i thought i was going to
be a big record producer
i was doing deals with clive davis guy
said nope that's not what you're here
for
but i love it
her mission changed in 1996. that's when
voters pass prop 209
banning affirmative action at
california's public universities
i want to change the world i don't like
what i see so instead of talking about
it what am i going to do about it
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
fired up price harnessed her
professional connections
to create the first black college expo
in los angeles
35 thousand people showed up
they were waiting in line and guess what
happened they sent out the riot gear
police
there were so many so many i think it
was too many so many black people
standing in line two and a half hours
and they thought it was gonna be a riot
and we were like what the heck and
everybody was just in line for education
one thousand dollar scholarship
due to the pandemic the expos are
virtual but the needs are greater than
ever
i heard you take phone calls in the
middle of the night in the early morning
you'll do anything for these kids i'll
do anything i know it's bad
it's bad it's good though but it's bad i
just want them to know that there are
great things out there waiting for them
and they can do anything
about 85 percent of the students come
from single-parent or
foster homes and some like 20-year-old
devin williams
are homeless those points of time i was
sleeping in cars
sleeping at parks raised in a violent
home
williams was 12 when he found his mother
dead from alcohol poisoning
at first i was in a dark place i'm not
gonna lie like the first couple like two
years
are in a really dark place he met price
at a black college expo
and she helped him find his way despite
my guardian angel for real like whenever
i have a tough time
i know i have nowhere else to go and i'm
just like you know she's always had my
back
covet has created desperate situations
price answers every call
for food money even laptops so students
can continue learning
and thriving i cry a lot but their tears
are joy too because a lot of them
see that they can do i feel like that
text that call it's only a minute
i mean to say hey i believe in you and
if we all did that
we'll be better world and while the
classroom shows students the light
price shows them the love where they can
then create their own
wonderful world for cbs this morning
jamie yukis
los angeles
helping kids is just her happy place and
it's infectious watching her
help other people five hundred thousand
kids to college because of her helping
hand
yeah timmy introduces us to the nicest
people yeah we love her
you're watching cbs this morning we'll
be right back